I'm gonna try a lot of different formats
I'm gonna see what sticks and then that
one I'm gonna double down like I called
the three in one rule can I film three
shorts at least in one hour and if I'm
not then maybe the idea isn't simple
enough when you get that first scroll
and people see it is there enough
information there to build tension and
then when I come to sit down to a video
or I'm sitting down with my editing team
I'm like all right how do we want to
approach this like what are the
different inspiration I like to say
Don't just take from one take from many
and then uh give credit and then put
your own spin on it
what does it really take right now to
make it as a Creator in the Creator
economy today I'm here with John ushai
who has been a YouTube and Instagram has
worked at YouTube and Instagram uh as an
employee has also interviewed some of
the most famous creators in the world
from Logan Paul to the Paris Hiltons
Mark robers and ultimately is deep in
research of what it takes to really
crush it in the crater economy So today
we're going to be hearing a little bit
about his story and learning some tips
that are practical for you growing in
your career John welcome to the show
what's up good to be here thanks for
having me Sean thanks so much for
meeting up at VidCon total chaos you
know being here in the lobby of the
Hyatt and here we are yeah yeah dude I
gotta say this is one of the first I've
been doing more podcasts I'm so excited
to sit down with you because I know how
smart your audience is and let's just
let's just give them all the secrets and
all the insights so let's get into it
yeah I'm excited because you you have
two Keynotes here so this is going to be
a Ritz session on increasing engagement
decreasing production time and stuff
like that but for those that are just
meeting you what are you up to if
they're learning a little bit about you
where you been and where you are now
yeah I like to say I spent eight years
at YouTube and Instagram and now making
videos about what I couldn't talk about
when I was on the inside and I like to
say with my video how many years are
both uh five years at YouTube and three
years at Instagram and what were your
titles a lot of different roles at
YouTube uh most recently before I left
there I was head of Creator product
marketing and had a chance to launch a
lot of the new monetization products the
thing I'm most proud of Creator is
Creator on the rise had a chance to
launch that and just see a lot of new
creators grow and come up through the
trending tab which is really exciting
obviously work with a lot of product and
Engineering folks on that and then on
Instagram I was one of their first hires
to help build their creator team kind of
like rewrite the Playbook that I learned
at YouTube but at Instagram and just uh
really think about it from a different
platform before going out on my own and
trying to implement those learnings yeah
now you got 354 000 subscribers on your
YouTube channel so you're creating
content on your own and you're sharing a
session on eight tips from an eight year
YouTube and Instagram Insider what are
some of the tips that you think are
working best right now for increasing
engagement and how you've grown over 200
million views with some of these tips
yeah I like to say that like um you know
history repeats itself and I remember
when I was working at YouTube we had a
chance to work with a lot of like big
creators celebrities and I'll never
forget
um James Corden you know who just like
was on late night and had his show just
came to an end he approached YouTube in
such an interesting way that he doesn't
often get credit for and I like to say
that there's two kind of creators in the
world there's the James corden's and
there's the Stephen colberts right and
Corden has his variety show right he has
so many different things that people
know about like carpool karaoke
um you know uh uh like um uh a crosswalk
musical
um like rock the mic like so many
different formats versus Stephen Colbert
has much fewer the monologue a musical
guest and interview and the show is over
and so I think what I saw with like him
and him his approach to YouTube was like
I'm gonna try lot of different formats
I'm going to see what sticks and then
that one I'm going to double down on and
I think so many creators are trying to
do a few formats they stain their Lane
they do a lot of monologue right they do
a lot of interviews and nothing wrong
with that like I do a lot of that too
but it's like how can you get outside of
your set how can you go on the street
how can you think about different
formats so I think one of the things
I've been able to see and I'm happy to
talk about all like we've tried out like
9 10 11 different formats and a few have
taken off just have popped off 40
million views 30 million views and
that's translated to long form uh you
know attraction as well yeah when I was
looking at your most viewed YouTube
shorts you really found one that really
worked and it's break that down it's
kind of comparing like two known people
with like a traditional celebrity and a
YouTube Creator exactly so I'm like a
lot of people obsessed over stats and
big data right I get it like I worked in
Silicon Valley but I'm like all right
what's the visceral like reaction now
like what's the emotional side of those
statistics so I'm sure you've seen all
those like variety articles like oh my
gosh the creators are more popular
celebrities I'm like but okay what is
what does that mean yeah you know what
does that mean when you show people on
the screen get that you know
generational age difference so I was
like you know what I'm gonna go ask
people is Logan Paul more popular than
Tom Hanks is Mr Beast most popular and
Tom Cruise like kind of find people who
for their respective you know Industries
traditional or social you know they they
uh are similar and just compare and the
results you know people recognizing
Logan Paul but not Tom Hanks blew me
away and led to that format taking off
and I think that's one that like on that
format alone you put out you know 20
different comparisons that have gotten
over
150 million views on that alone so it's
crazy to see that and that's just one
example yeah and that's wild and so for
those
it's such a powerful tip for those
listening to think about experimenting
with different formats how many failed
attempts led up to a winning attempt
would you say a lot and I'd say I
categorize the failures in two ways
there's the failure of the that format
in and of itself in the introduction
um which I could talk about and there's
a failure of formats and I never even
like took off so for the first part I I
would start out the video I was like hey
guys we're here in Hollywood and um you
want to ask people are creators more
popular than celebrities first up we
have Tom Hanks versus Logan Paul like
that is such a long-winded way to open
it and then I'm like you know what how
can I make this faster with editing and
I was like okay I'm gonna put the faces
on there and I'm gonna just like say
okay Tom Hanks or Logan Paul but not
enough context then I was like you know
I'm gonna go to FedEx I'm gonna print
out a literal side-by-side poster board
with their faces on it and I'm just
gonna ask the simplest version of the
question with the most visual you know
stimulus and say
um who are these two people
that's it yeah that's it that's that's
the whole thing and then what most
people don't see is that while I'm on
the street I actually Sean have an
entire
um binder of like 10 of these
comparisons so that you could batch
produce yes 100
um and and that's another one of my like
big beliefs and something that I think
has led to our viewership in the
subscribers in the first year is like
can I film I call it a three-in-one rule
can I film three shorts at least in one
hour and if I'm not then maybe the idea
isn't simple enough so you really refine
the idea and having a physical prop in a
real world was very powerful and then it
started to work you start to double down
on it what are some of the other tips
from that session you're talking about
eight tips was that just one of them
that was one is like thinking about like
the variety format B according Creator
not a Colbert Creator is what I like to
say uh the other one we talked about is
like the three in one rule like like
really use that as a way to simplify how
can you make three videos in one the
other way I think like to think about it
I call this the first frame Rule and I
know you guys put this in one of your
videos in a compilation uh that was
really cool to see on your channel but I
like to say people obsessed over like oh
the first three seconds I'm like uh I
kind of think it's the zero second Mark
today yeah and so I'm like when you get
that first scroll and people see it is
there enough information there to build
tension you know yes so I'm like all
right the the physical print out of
there there's two heads or some kind of
comparison and I have a mic where I'm
like trying to like immediately throw
the mic to them like who are these two
people
so fast so fat you you get it right no
build up that introduction those are the
many failed attempts uh that led to that
succinct version that popped off so the
first frame rule is another thing like
if you're not you know setting it up in
that first frame then you you're it's
probably not succinct enough you know at
least for short
looking at some of uh those by far like
here one two three four five top shorts
are all that format but cutting over to
some of your most viewed videos uh what
lessons did you learn I mean your
biggest one was with Danny Duncan yeah
yeah yeah and it's is there a clip from
it and the full-length interview
both are your most viewed video the full
length interview is announced they're
two different videos one is an hour-long
sit down where uh like whenever I do an
interview with someone I try to make it
the best interview they've done you know
and so Danny got emotionally shared
things he's never shared on camera it's
like full like how did he grow his
channel to seven million sell 150 in
merch the other video is 24 hours with
him and it was like spending a day with
him in his hometown of Inglewood because
he's bought over a hundred acres of land
and like seeing how how does a YouTuber
develop build land think about this is
almost like his little city you know got
it so they're two separate videos but
yeah they've been most popular long form
and when you say so what is your
philosophy in interviews you've got they
come to your studio
no I go to them okay that's why I really
respect what you're I mean this is like
uh I go to them yeah yeah we built a
studio and we're trying to have more
people come to us but I will make it as
easy as possible okay so you go to them
and and then set up and really give the
margin and the time to do it because one
of the things you do that's cool is you
do the pie chart of how you earn money
and you wheel out a little pie chart and
then people draw yeah five percent
Affiliates yeah 20 brand deals so but
what is your other Philosophy for those
that would want to do interview shows
what you think makes a good interview
You Gotta Have A short segment in your
long form like bake it in like so that
draw your income segment that you're
talking about where we're sitting down
in an interview then I'm like Sean how
do you make your money as a Creator all
right we have a segment called draw your
income like outcomes like this dry erase
board that we got with a circle on it
five percent you know uh cutouts and I
was like you know what this is designed
for it to be valuable in the context of
an interview but then for me to take it
as a draw your income short smart yeah
so we have a lot of those coming out and
so I'm like okay can that be a way to
you know kind of marry short form and
long form as opposed to just thinking
about one versus other okay so do you
think that Danny's influence was why
those did so well yes but also Danny has
had other interviews even in the past
few months they've got nowhere near that
so I think that the preparation the
production I try to build a lot of
trucks that took over a year a bus like
just chatting yeah and thinking about
like okay what's something that's like I
could share that most people don't know
about somebody who's already very known
and thumbnail hook the opening structure
editing you put effort into editing
everything yeah yeah and uh okay amazing
then your third most viewed video is a
great thumbnail and it's your tips on
ex-youtube employee exposes good word
how to grow a YouTube channel and that
one is continues to get views and what
what did you learn about that video
first off I I think that the whole idea
of like can you find something and take
out and turn into a series so that X
YouTube employee explains we're turning
into a whole series where I feel like I
could talk about stuff now being on the
outside but still having the knowledge
on being on the inside and applying it
as a Creator so one I was like all right
I want to try something that I could uh
serialize turn into a form an ex-youtube
employee explains we're also going to
debut X Instagram employee explains on
my channel because I I had a chance to
work there and there's a lot of just a
lot of stuff I'm sure like you see like
I'm like that's not uh that's not
actually how Instagram works that's not
how YouTube I feel like I just feel
um like I could talk about that stuff
more but the biggest thing I learned is
like can I launch something that's
serialized and then can I also just like
have a really tight script before I sit
down yeah you know and make sure every
second of that video has something of
value that you know to me it's like I
like to say I need to write it down on
the page before I take it on the stage
right whether that's video whether
that's uh actually speaking it so
um to me scripting is like I was like oh
okay it works I need to repeat it I love
this serialized idea I actually just
caught an Instagram reel it was an
editing tip the whole thing captured my
attention and at the end and he said and
make sure
to check back tomorrow because I'm going
to be sharing a hundred of these tips
and and I was like dude that's so smart
so what could you what how could you map
a hundred yeah create a series and if
any one of them popped up it's gonna you
know kind of cross promote the rest of
the series exactly thinking in series
thinking in something that you can
multiply it's also probably the
sustainability in the crater economy
which is one of my questions for you
because you know I think I don't know
how old VidCon is it's close to 10 years
it's over I think it's uh yeah
definitely over 10. I think I was here
10 years ago I think I might have been
at 2013. yeah um and which seems wild
what's what is crazy is the landscape
changes people really come and people go
people who seem like they were the most
famous maybe are gone now for multiple
different reasons from your perspective
because you also have massive longevity
in the Creator economy
what do you think are some of the things
creators should be thinking about when
it comes to sustainability not burning
out so many articles about the mental
health challenges of being a Creator
what's your take on that I think to me
the two things that make for a really
long career as a career are are you
experienced and are you entertaining and
I find too many people try to rely on
one and it may lead to burnout like for
example I find that a lot of folks now
it's like like you know being
entertaining on camera dancing or like
creating these skits like it's something
that like like is I think people have to
ask them so is this something that you
could do for the next seven years eight
years ten years even and if not how can
you think about diversifying today
either with different formats which is
why we see a lot of people doing
podcasts much easier with products you
know launching something that doesn't
rely on content or if it does you could
plug it in seamlessly or you experienced
about something
um and can you like maybe get your
delivery a little bit better are you
ready to start or grow your YouTube
channel do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots join this free web
class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com right I
remember I did an interview with Jordan
matter who is one of the oldest
YouTubers across 10 million subscribers
right
um I think at the time of our interviews
54 55 which is incredible right he's
he's huge he's at that age and I asked
him a similar question and he's like
yeah I think it's like Yeah The
Experience he was a photographer for
many years and for him he had that
bucket down he just had to figure out
how to make it entertaining how to bring
it to life and so I think you have those
two things and you think about it and
then you build a team around it yeah I
mean how can I ask you questions too is
it like yeah or I mean how do you think
about like
um longevity in terms of you as Sean on
versus the think media brand because I
think that's another way I've seen
people do it you've brought in hosts
yeah yeah exactly and I think for me you
know my backgrounds uh in the church
world and one of the things that I
learned was seeing senior pastors wait
too long to think about succession
because a lot of people who hold the mic
a lot of people who hold the Vlog camera
a lot of people you're like okay this is
on me I'm gonna be the person I'm the
communicator I'm the one doing it and I
think that the early you actually think
about replacing yourself even if you
don't plan to go anywhere still the
better you are it's just if you can step
into that mindset so what I would watch
is they'd start all of a sudden maybe
their energy their health something's
happening there's challenges they're
facing so they're like oh maybe I should
start preparing success and I think if
you're thinking about it then it's too
late so I am so grateful for that lesson
spending some years in Ministry and
thinking about okay one I in a way got
lucky because the channel was called
think media I do have a channel on my
first and last name I don't really
upload there and then two do what could
it look like it's very organic I didn't
actually immediately think let's do
multiple content creators I ran into
Omar while I was working out at Fitness
19. we had worked together at a church I
was like would you want to collab he was
more videographer first I was like you
can make videos and then we had Heather
for a while now we have Nolan and we're
actually going to do auditions and now
we're moving into the full creators of
building the next generation of media
companies so you know drop a comment if
you want to you know be on think media
legit like I don't know let's talk you
know yeah and so we're thinking about so
I think it's starting to like steer the
ship that way and then I think studying
it intentionally I also were so
education and I think education is maybe
a little bit different I really love
Linus Tech tips I think what they're
doing is incredible I think that
entertainments I may be similar to
you're trying to put other people on but
uh Dave Ramsey's one who's he's thinking
about he said it's his succession plan
and he's created Ramsay personalities
you know who that is of course I know
damn I'm not as familiar with the whole
Ramsay personalities like he's bringing
like hosts 20 million views on YouTube a
month right now Clips so yeah and he has
them sit with him so one of the things
would be like he's the main host and
it's like he'd bring someone by his side
to kind of Mentor them but it also
introduces them and and diverse you know
different ethnic backgrounds kind of
different ages to hit different demos
and so it's his succession plan to build
out Ramsay personalities so I started
thinking I'm actually going to turn 40
this year
you look great man what is what is what
is his skincare routine man anybody know
I need to you know what it is that's
what that's what we'll talk about a new
channel yeah yeah I'm starting a new one
and uh I'm starting a network marketing
company too actually so you could sign
up under just kidding but uh uh but yeah
so he's doing it like 65. you know and
I'm like why not think about it now
because I don't plan on going anywhere
but I think the sooner you think about
it and I think maybe reinvesting which
is a big challenge it's like kind of the
leadership CEO build a team can you
create a vision big enough that really
talented creators Vision can live inside
of it can you also not be like weird and
and realize like we just want to be
chill like hey you know Omar what do you
want to do Nolan what do you want to do
but you also need some level of
and the final thing I think about is two
illustrations the office
it still was it was sad when Michael
Scott left but it kept going you know
and so they TV shows they sign people so
I thought about like a sports team and
and we're not even fully there yet but
kind of thinking about like hey could
you roll with us for like a year or two
sign a contract and different things
um and then Wu-Tang Clan is the other
one actually
it was the idea that what would happen
if we also had some of our individual
projects but if nine of us got together
and made something that's a little bit
bigger yeah and uh and then value tame
it Patrick David he's building up media
company he offered his conservative news
kind of now he was Business and
Entrepreneurship and I don't know if
it's more of a media play but he offered
Tucker Matt he offered uh oh I saw
yesterday yeah which which probably was
nowhere near what he probably could come
in but a smart move too even for the pr
play and if he said either way it would
have been like smart yeah yeah but I
guess you start getting that world where
I mean we can't do that kind of stuff
yet I don't even know if that would
matter for teaching Tech and camera
reviews but anyways just a few thoughts
like I just kind of study in the world
thinking about it trying to stay humble
learn and figure it out as we go it's
funny like how like for creators
listening to this like how much like as
you start you already put the wheels in
motion for either being a Solo Channel
or like a umbrella for other
personalities yeah so I think like for
what you're trying to do like with the
think media umbrella you've set yourself
up really well for longevity and I think
the last thing is also trying to tracked
out like no doubt about it your
personality is going to carry a big
weight to it but seeing how practical
could this be if we made this like um
CNET or the verge like when I watched
Cena admittedly or even the ver I
haven't made a connection with any of
those content creators but the brand has
enough value to it that like whatever
content they put out Vox sometimes too
like maybe maybe some people have
affinity for who's doing the voiceover
but I don't know I'm like it's just if I
care about the topic so thinking about
tools for creators our Niche and we're
trying to get back to it as far as
cameras gear like they could be more
sustainable trying to think like that's
off of just if I'm not pedaling the bike
then the whole thing falls down and
obviously yeah I think it's tough I
think a lot of creators are wrestling
with these questions you're doing a
great job man it's really cool to see so
as we land the plane you have another
keynote here
and you have studied extensively Beyonce
yeah and you have discovered though as
much as most creators might think what
could I possibly learn from Beyonce the
superstar that could apply for like the
Practical Creator but there are some
tips you've learned from her that can
boost our creativity there's things in
terms of how to reach billions on a
budget that seems like
you've created tension there because
Beyonce's budget is huge she said put
some respect on the check you know what
I mean she's doing all right I think
they just bought a record house Jay-Z
and Beyonce yeah yeah somebody was about
the record 50 million dollar house or
something and so uh so what are some
tips from Beyonce from your presentation
so it that's like a great clarification
like to me like billions on a budget is
not Beyonce's budget it's if you're
starting out and you're a Creator on a
tiny budget right it's like it's like
she reaches billions but how can you
take that and make it your own okay um
but yeah I studied her career like
probably more than any like thesis or
whatever I did in school like 20 years
ago how did she stay relevant and the
biggest thing I saw is that she is so
good at adapting work from so many
different sources around the world like
the talk and I wish I had some of the
visuals here maybe we could put it on
screen I'm gonna try to make a video
about this
um as well but essentially if you study
like single ladies that video that took
off you know Connie called it like one
of the best videos of all time uh it
actually comes from 1969 Bob Fosse a
choreographer who
um took these like this this very a
minimalist background put three women
dancing in actually very similar
choreography to Beyonce
um and she adapted that and made it into
Single Ladies but what's fascinating is
like she didn't go through the 1960s
Archive of like studying Bob Foster
choreography see she saw a DJ Unk remix
of that to walk it out remember when I
walk it out like took off like in 2008
so like she saw a remix of the original
and made her own remix and she is so
deliberate about trying to fill like
what I like to call and what a lot of
advertisers and marketers called their
swipe file have you ever heard that term
100 yeah so it's like uh uh you know
like as she sees stuff she like stores
it right and she's like okay when I'm
coming out like with my next video my
next tour my song I'm gonna go to the
swipe file which is just like stuff I've
swiped like
um you know from like things that have
inspired you but she's so conscious and
deliberate about it that it it just
blows me away that um like her makeup
artist for example is giving her ideas
for example like a performance that she
gave at the 2011 Billboard Music Awards
is actually adapted from Lorella
cookerini in 2011 who made a similar
visual performance in Italy but Beyonce
took that took a lot of different
inspiration and so I think it just
reminds me of I think it's a Mark Twain
quote that's like inspiration I'm
paraphrasing it's either conscious and
you're aware of where you heard of it or
subconscious and you don't realize it
and I think so many people who say
they're original let's say don't realize
that the inspiration is subconscious and
if you could consciously fill yourself
with like more inspiration whether
that's like I'm Gonna Keep a folder of
all the best YouTube thumbnails which is
what I do you know when I see something
I click on I'm like why did I click on
that and I have a folder which I'm happy
to share with anyone if they want to DM
me or like like I I'd be curious to you
like what's in your swipe file in fact
I'm like whoa that's an amazing intro
hook
um literally do a screen recording put
that in the folder of my best intros yes
and then when I come to sit down to a
video or I'm sitting down with my
editing team I'm like all right how do
we want to approach this like what are
the different inspiration I like to say
Don't just take from one take from many
and then give credit and then put your
own spin on it and that it's kind of
like how you Channel Beyonce and there's
a lot more to it but that's in a
nutshell and I think you you said
something like but she's not doing copy
and paste yeah yeah yeah she's doing
copy and taste yeah so my money line
that I was like okay how do I like
summarize this uh it's like okay so
everybody's talking about copy and paste
she's all about copy with taste and so
copy and paste is like you steal from
One Source you give no credit uh like uh
you don't lift the art you just like
replicate it copy with taste is like you
share the credit you you adapt from
multiple sources not just one and you
kind of elevate it in a new way and just
leave it out in the world for somebody
else to copy what tastes so yeah you
know what's kind of funny is there's
some critics of like
The Tick Tock and shorts remix there's
some critics so maybe the react format
and how much echoing it can feel like
there is on YouTube but there's a
documentary called Everything is a remix
really good we'll actually link to it I
think they eventually it was on Vimeo
originally and I think that we could put
it we'll put in the show notes it's very
worth your time but it'll take even
people like Quentin Tarantino and scene
from scene of like Kill Bill they'll
show you exact scenes in other films
that are just structured the same way
yeah like shot for shot almost of course
it's original because it's his own thing
in the ways but he's inspired by
cinematography from these other films
that were inspiration for him and it's
bringing it into his work so why maybe
things are faster now and certainly
there's some where people are just doing
copy and paste and they're not copying
with taste but I think that this is not
even a new thing I think the art form of
remixing making it original but
consuming a lot of Divergent content and
then synthesizing it
is a very powerful Insight that a lot of
us can learn from 100 and like it's just
uh it's crazy like how much of that goes
on and we don't always know the original
Source you know sure yeah
um okay is it too late to start YouTube
absolutely not absolutely not I have so
many thoughts on like I think I think
it's now is the second best time to
start a YouTube channel why is that okay
2012 2013 things are taking off not as
much competition like I think it's
always easy to grow when a platform's
growing right yeah things are more
subtle now I think the biggest
opportunity and why I left my jobs at
Instagram and YouTube is there is such a
need for more professionalism in the
Creator economy like it it blows my mind
how many Brands we talk to and I'm like
wait you like okay you have talking
points like we're gonna send you a
script we're gonna send it to you for
review here's our timeline for the video
um uh uh like we're gonna take it
through and like uh you know like what
like we want to like study your blog
post we want to go through like I even
like watch their old earnings reports to
figure out what can I say for a brand to
really be a good ambassador to them in
our like sponsored segments or like
we're consulting which we do I'm like
you know uh uh just how can you make
them know that you care about their
goals or metrics or kpis
um and I don't know I'm like I'm always
baffled that like I talk with creators
and they don't ask those questions to
Brands when they work with them this is
a big unlock there's so much need for
professionalism big time so if you up
your professionalism You're Gonna Stand
Out oh yeah and I mean with just one
other nugget if I could give
um like if you guys are trying I don't
know I keep addressing the cameras but
it's just natural uh
um it's if you're pitching a brand and
trying to get a brand deal and you have
a team
um put your team on your Media Kit
you know I find that like people like
are like whoa oh I'm not just hiring
John I'm hiring his editors
um you know his operators like his his
content strategies like like we have an
entire team that puts together that
content so it's almost like you're not
just hiring an individual you're hiring
a mini creative agency and letting them
know what they're investing in and and
that makes them more comfortable with
like the cost that they're putting into
it because I'm like I'm hiring like a
lot of people to make this piece of work
come to life and so that's something
that I'm like uh you know I'm surprised
I'm not saying that not every Creator is
I'm surprised more creators haven't done
totally and if you step in and have had
a job before I think we're gonna see a
rise of more corporate creators and and
seeing that you know them leave that and
start a career what is uh from all the
interviews you've done with Critters and
celebrities I think you've had Jake Paul
Paris Hilton all kinds of people out of
all these different interviews and
conversations what's one of your
favorite moments
and an Insight that you gained from one
of those interviews that impacted your
life
yeah
um I think two one I have an interview
coming out with Liza koshy that I'm
super excited about because she like
it's been a while since she sat down and
talked like this candidly and just
talking about how she thought about her
career and like how she's uploading
videos I got 20 30 million views but now
how she's trying to like use everything
she learned to make an even longer
career in media uh so I think a lot of
those lessons are like what like and I
think about like what can I be doing
right now that I can see myself doing in
10 years you know like I really want to
play the long game and just set and if
I'm repeating a piece of feedback to an
editor or somebody on my team I'm like
how can I create a document we literally
have a document that's like five six
pages long that's all of our editing
best practices right and so I'm like
before I review something I want you to
go through this checklist and see does
this meet all of the things I make for a
video that will go on our Channel
they'll go on our socials and the second
one is I interviewed Logan Paul and um
there's so many good nuggets in that
interview but one of it that stood out
is he I talked about how do you write
tweets you know how do you literally
write tweets you know because he's had a
lot of them like take off and what have
you learned and uh he told me about how
try to avoid absolutes as much as
possible you know and and try to avoid
superlatives which which is you know
it's something I'm trying to get better
at because like things are so nuanced
it's hard not to do that because that's
what gets clicked it's funny he says
that because that's what gets clicks
though usually if it blows up is
absolute I know I know but it's like I
know it's like trying to be nuanced with
it but is that him saying a lesson he's
learned the hard way
said absolutes and seeing it kind of
backfire some way but I think about it
more of like okay like maybe like do you
have a hook that's more like towards an
absolute but then like and Twitter's a
tough platform for that but it's like um
can you like bring people in which is
why I'm like okay I see the value short
form the long form is where you could
let it breathe can you open up Nuance
leave room for conversation you lean
away but yeah if you go absolute
it's interesting yeah like we could have
a conversation about like okay uh the
best way to start a YouTube channel in
2023 is to start as a media brand not as
an individual but I'm like no I think
that as an individual it's better
because you could build more connection
all this stuff but then we should
acknowledge like nuances within that
totally it could go either way it could
go either way there was literally a
conference where I heard it it was
trafficking conversion in San Diego more
of a heavier marketing conference but
they talked about movement makers
speaking absolutes tell me more what do
you mean and they they said and now they
were speaking about these entrepreneur
voices but they were saying like if you
look at someone like a garyvee
that everything he says is an absolute
yeah he'll be like I remember in 2010 or
11 he wrote the book Thank You economy
and we went to Bellingham Washington to
his talk and on stage he was like my
friends
if you are not using
search.twitter.com
today you will not be in business
tomorrow
and I promise you the 500 people in that
room none of them are using it only 10
started to use it and they didn't stay
consistent and most of them are probably
still in business that you know what I
mean like I mean he has a point kind of
but like you know but it's just and and
their point they they had like five
elements of movement makers and one of
them was that actually they speak in
absolute so anyways that's it I guess
you know as things get more fragmented I
guess there is a need to do that to get
people's attention but I I think it's
like once you have that attention how do
you at least acknowledge or wrestle with
the Nuance in what you're talking about
and I think what's hard is if you
actually go out and just make a decree
like that that's kind of one thing but
these days everything's getting clipped
so it's not that you actually are
speaking in absolutes but you only have
so much time and that makes an absolute
Point context can be fleshed out a good
communicator is going to maybe allow for
nuances for sure for sure and I think
it's up to the viewers as well and
today's day and age you'd be like all
right I see that clip I know what
they're doing that got my attention let
me find more material from them to help
explain that or help me grapple with it
or let me hear it from other sources so
yeah the game yeah it's kind of the game
well hey you've added a ton of value
where can people follow you what are you
up to the YouTube channel what other
social media accounts are you active on
yeah check check me out if you go to at
ushai on all socials my YouTube channel
is where I put a lot of just you know
stuff that takes probably months to edit
uh really try to put out stuff that uh
you know values the notification that
goes out and then um our Discord if you
go to
created.club we have about 2 000
creators in there helping each other
roast thumbnails uh videos I'm pretty
active and they're asking answering
questions about all my experience but
yeah man it's just a joy to be hero on
your podcast and uh and and uh just keep
rooting you on man I'm a big fan of
think media man I appreciate that and uh
definitely check out the show notes for
everything subscribe if you're not
subscribed share this out think video
podcast John thank you so much